Movie fans might have noticed that Jackie Chan
has appeared in fewer and fewer American films
throughout the years. After he became one
of Hong Kong's biggest and most profitable
silver-screen stars thanks to his work as an actor
and stuntman in martial arts and action movies,
it seemed inevitable that Chan
would take over Hollywood.
In 1998, he took a giant leap toward that
feat when he scored a role in his first big
international blockbuster, Rush Hour. Playing
opposite Chris Tucker in the action-comedy film,
Chan became instantly recognizable to fans all
across the globe. From there, he followed up the
first Rush Hour with a handful of sequels and many
other American projects like The Spy Next Door,
all three Kung Fu Panda movies, a 2010 remake
of The Karate Kid starring Jaden Smith.
It's undeniable that Chan is one
of the biggest stars in the world,
but he's largely disappeared from the American
spotlight, though he's still churning out films
in his native Hong Kong. Here's the real reason
Jackie Chan stopped filming American movies.
In an October 2020 interview with Filmelier,
which was translated into English by MovieWeb,
Chan revealed the reason why he's been sticking to
movies made in Asia lately. As he told the outlet,
"[I've] never left America, [but I haven't
been able to] find the right script."
Unfortunately for Chan, he seems to get
pigeonholed a lot. Chan referenced the seven-year
gap between 2010's Karate Kid and 2017's The
Foreigner co-starring Pierce Brosnan, and said,
"All these years after The Karate
Kid, I received so many scripts,
but the role is [always] a Hong Kong
policeman. That's why it took me seven
years to accept a role in another
Hollywood film, with The Foreigner."
"I said can I have something
different like Mamma Mia?"
Ultimately, Chan wants to diversify his roles
and get into more dramatic work. During the
same interview, Chan explained that his roles in
The Karate Kid and The Foreigner are the type of
parts he's seeking out these days. In The Karate
Kid, Chan played a maintenance man who's actually
a kung fu master; he becomes the mentor to
a 12-year-old boy who recently moved to Hong
Kong and wants to learn to defend himself. Chan's
role in The Foreigner was just as interesting. He
played an ex-special forces operative who became a
restaurateur in London following the Vietnam War.
However, when his teenage daughter dies in a
terrorist bombing, Chan's character seeks revenge.
These parts in Hollywood films allowed Chan
to explore new territory, which is something
he wants to do more of on screen. If the
right Hollywood movie script comes along,
Chan would presumably jump at the chance. That
just hasn't happened yet, as he told Filmelier,
"I want to make sure that every year the
audience can see so many different sides
of Jackie Chan [...] I would like audiences
to consider me as an actor who can do action,
not just as an action star. I
don't like to repeat myself."
This isn't the first big announcement Chan has
made about the future of his career. At the 2012
Cannes Film Festival, the icon admitted that he
was stepping away from action movies. He revealed,
"I will ask my body how long
I can go [...] I tell you,
I am not young anymore [...]
I am really, really tired."
It also isn't the first time that Chan has
discussed his desire for audiences to see him
as more than just an action movie star. During the
Cannes Film Festival press conference for Chinese
Zodiac in 2012, the actor shared that
he wanted to show the world "the real
Jackie Chan." To do that, Chan's plan
was to move away from action-heavy roles
and into more dramatic territory. He explained,
"I don't just want to be an action star, I
want to be a true actor [...] I want to be
an Asian Robert De Niro. I want to get rid of
my image. So, for the last ten years I've done
other films like The Karate Kid,
where I'd rather play an old man.
I want the audience to know I'm not just
about fighting or comedy, also I can act."
With all this considered, Chan also
recently teased a fourth Rush Hour movie,
so it seems that nothing's off the table just yet.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite celebs are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.